[Musique]
ils vont au terrain de foot ils sont dans le
les places sont dans les jardins et bien et
il y a des gens qui n'en veulent pas même dans le
carrés ou sur des terrains de football ou dans
les jardins et je ne les veux pas non plus dans
norddelta
eh bien dernièrement, ils ont commencé avec l'un des
les derniers projets car nous n'avons plus
il y a plus de terrains pour faire des quartiers
et on n'y va pas les caprices ont commencé
pour migrer et à la recherche de nourriture, ils sont entrés
dans les quartiers voir des capybaras me donne
le plaisir me donne je ne sais comment remercier Dieu pour lui
où je vis et pouvoir profiter
mais il y a des gens qui ne le font pas
veut parce qu'ils mangent de l'herbe parce qu'ils
ils abîment la pelouse ils ne nous dérangent pas
capybaras ce que nous voulons, c'est voir comment
vivre avec les capybaras et nous voulons
demander à nordelta de faire une réservation
avec une flore et une faune indigènes
notre objectif
[Musique]